making strides for friendship one local
non-profit held its annual event today
to help create a more inclusive
community bianca holman has the story
a perfect day to gather and recognize
friendship it was all smiles during this
fourth annual one mile walk in community
carnival you doubled in size two years
ago before the before covid people want
to get out people want to get out of the
house people want to celebrate and walk
for a good cause this is all for the
friendship circle of las vegas the group
pairs teens and young adult volunteers
with other youth who have a disability
through shared experiences bonds form
especially throughout kobit the
isolation was even more everyone needs a
friend everyone could benefit from a
friend so all we do is just make those
friendships happen and let them take off
and
the fruits the success that we've seen
the friendships that have been created
is remarkable ultimately creating an
inclusive community where everyone feels
accepted bianca holmen live local now